on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk TV
[Music]
tonight up Facebook and uncensored one
year on from Liz trust have we recovered
from the budget that broke Britain and
other people that dragged us into the
Maya sorry for what they did
quasi-quarting was the brains behind the
lettuce the chancellor whose policies
self-imploded so tonight I'll ask him if
he will finally apologize to the British
people for the financial hurts that he
and Liz trust calls them
22 year old British students been killed
in a Russian motorstrike while fighting
for Ukraine I'll speak exclusively to
his family
[Music]
live from the news building in London
this is Piers Morgan uncensored
is Piers Morgan uncensored good evening
from London welcome to Piers Morgan
uncensored hundreds of schools across
the country have had to close buildings
of a dodgy concrete that's left them in
danger of collapse it's become a
full-blown crisis for the government and
an early Christmas present for fans of
lazy metaphors critics say there's
governments crumbling before our eyes
the walls are falling in after 13 years
of Tory rule they failed to fix the roof
while the Sun was shining we don't yet
know why it took so long for the
government to act we don't yet know how
long it will take to fix it we don't yet
know how much that will cost but what we
do know is absolutely nobody is to blame
his prime minister Rishi sunak accused
of cutting School budgets when he was
Chancellor are you to blame for what's
happening now and you want to apologize
to parents I think that is completely
and utterly wrong
says the Prime Minister Jillian Keegan
Secretary of State for Education First
said it was quote not her responsibility
before blowing up in this hot mic to
raid
but you're saying that the government is
not responsible ultimately for the
safety of children in schools the school
building's responsibility is with local
authorities and multi-academy trees does
anyone ever say you know what you've
done a good job because everyone else
has sat on there and done nothing no no
signs of that no everybody else was sat
on their asses said the education Chief
who was sat on her ass on holiday in
Spain when the school closures were
ordered
well today a department triumphantly
tweeted most schools unaffected well
that's great news at least we know the
line after the election 40 of Tories
lose their seats most unaffected this
crisis has exposed a phobia that's
gripping politicians around the world
it's the fear of taking responsibility
or saying sorry for anything President
Biden said it was quote not his
responsibility when classified documents
were found piled in his garage next to
his beloved Corvette asked if you take
responsibility of the Taliban
Afghanistan Biden said this don't you
bear some responsibility for the outcome
if the Taliban ends up back in control
and women end up losing no I don't look
do I bear responsibility zero
responsibility and yet it was entirely
your responsibility Mr President
everybody knows what happened over in
Afghanistan the tragic consequences not
least for millions of Afghan women now
being suppressed once again by the
Taliban wolves Boris Johnson infamously
borne their responsibility for literally
anything including an investigation that
was found he lied to Parliament about
lockdown parties and launched a campaign
of abuse against his critics it was all
a terrible Witch Hunt he said Donald
Trump's a Godfather taking their
responsibility a former president who'd
apparently rather go to jail than admit
he lost an election and a year ago today
Liz trust became prime minister for
disastrous and historically awful 44
days a friend and chance of quasi-cuate
broke Britain with a mini budget that
tanked the pound crashed the markets
blew up mortgages for millions of people
well who bears that responsibility who's
sorry it's pretty clear that most people
are now still paying the price
but apologies there have been none trust
in politics is at an all-time low
because so few politicians just want to
throw their hands up and go it's on me
gov and I'm sorry every leader blames a
guy who messed it up before them and the
one who made it worse afterwards look
it's hard to admit you're wrong
apparently I've been told that but if
politicians want to rebuild trust it
starts with admitting they broke it in
the first place and occasionally just
saying I sorry it was me
well I'm joined now by the former
Chancellor quasiquatic great to see you
you've never said sorry I've never what
happened a year just over a year ago
what I've said I bear responsibility for
it why not say something and what I want
to do is to make sure that we actually
get back uh to a growth agenda because
what's your responsibility for well I
think the way that we delivered it and
the and the speed with which it was
delivered was wrong and I put my I've
put up my hand uh frequently and said we
should have taken more time we should
have had a more balanced approach uh and
I've said that repeatedly in interviews
uh on television what I'm really I'm
really curious why you've never been
able to bring yourself to say the simple
words I'm sorry after all the damage
that was inflicted by that ruinous
44-day regime of Liz truss and I'm sure
that you would say and we'll come to
this a lot of it was on her but I'm not
here to apportion blame I mean that's
the that's one of the reasons
that wasn't the reasons why I get it if
you take responsibility why you also not
prepared to say sorry so I think there's
a it sounds like a loyally distinction
but I think there's a difference between
saying I was responsible sounds like a
bit like a kid because actually a lot of
the debate and you've probably been
following this if you look at things
like slavery and reparations and all of
that all of that is all about saying I'm
sorry and in in those instances the
people themselves weren't entirely
responsible I agree that happens two or
three hundred years I agree with you so
so what I don't see why people today
should be apologizing for the behavior
no I get that of ancestors 300 years ago
so but you were you were the guy no but
again as in government uh there are lots
of different people lots of different
agencies lots of different people who
are involved so it doesn't make any
sense it doesn't make any sense for
someone like for example Jillian Keegan
to say sorry when there's all of this
stuff happened uh over over many decades
and there were lots of things
let's talk about the mini budget yeah
there were lots of things that were
going on you say it crashed pound the
the the
um Federal Reserve had put up interest
rates and the Japanese Yen and the Euro
were at 50 years the main reason as you
know the main reason the pound tanked as
rapidly as it did for a week for a week
but the main reason
because you had these billions and
billions of unfunded taxes and where and
where
straw to break the Campbell's back was
actually the guilts it wasn't the
currency Market it was actually the what
were called the ldi's long-term guilt
Market where interest rates went up and
there was there was a run on that and
the bank intervened my own view I mean I
didn't sack myself I wanted to stick it
out no no and see it through
um the Prime Minister took a different
route and but do you accept that what
you did was a massive mistake so I think
that the delivery of it
um was was a mistake left a lot to be
designed over 45 billion of tax cuts
that haven't been funded even to even to
a sort of
non-academic Financial brain like mine
so look like lunacy no but the the it
was a store that brings a camel's back
so she campaigned very clearly not to
increase or a corporation tax during the
leadership and to reverse the ni
increases and that was 35 million and
what what where we went too far was
probably in trying to get rid of the 45p
rate so the point about the reason I
think principally it went wrong was that
there was just too much in it because
there was immediate harm
to millions of people and there was in
the country it was a very tough it was a
very turbulent yeah your turbulent yeah
you're definitely yeah your turbulence
was another person's more except and
I've also openly said that you know I
was exposed uh ironically enough uh to
that as well I mean lots of people so
here's my question for you again I I'm
really I'm not going to come here and
say uh wear a hair shirt and apologize
and why not and say something why not
because I want to look forward and I
want to I'm sure you do but I want to
look back for a year old I don't think
that's good but the reason I want to
look back is Rishi sunak was in
competition with this trust to be the
prime minister at the time and he warned
when she was talking about all these tax
cut she was going to do he warned this
so I don't think the responsible thing
to do right now is launch into some
unfunded spree of borrowing and more
debt that will just make inflation worse
it will make the problem longer let's be
clear we have inflation because of our
monetary policy that we haven't been
tough enough on the monetary Supply
that's the way I would address that
issue okay but it is wrong interest
rates up mortgage is Nightmare it is it
is Liz we have to be honest we have to
be honest but borrowing your way out of
inflation isn't a plan it's a fairy tale
well he was right I think he was right
to an extent he was right completely no
no because I think where she was right
where we were right was identifying
growth and that will be an issue that
you will have endless conversations with
politicians in the next few years
because it's very unclear if you have a
very high tax system which we're
currently in how you get growth I think
where we went wrong and I'm very happy
to confess this is there was just too
much uh too quickly I think if she'd
done the measures she campaigned on I
think we'd have been okay and of course
you've got to remember that this is on
top of the energy Intervention which was
cost billions no listen there were lots
of other things yeah yeah so and I'm not
disputing that I just I find it
interesting that politicians today find
it increasingly difficult to just say
sorry so when the when the consequences
of their decisions and actions you were
Chancellor she was the Prime Minister
when the direct consequences were felt
immediately by millions of people so I
think as I said
I mean you are a moderate you know
reasonable person but politicians were
always been no one's going to do that
you've got to be you've got to be you
gotta apologize for this you've got to
apologize for that were you the shortest
living Chancellor in history well
actually Ian McLeod was but that's a
difference so you're the second shortest
living but hang on okay shortest living
chance from history she was one of the
shortest the shortest the shortest prime
minister 44 days that's right Mayhem
right she couldn't even Outlast a
lettuce so on every metric of political
life putting aside everything else the
pair of you will go down in history
whether you like it or not as disasters
in that period right and I simply asked
given the magnitude so I'm not coming
here to to formally apologize why not
sorry I am what I am saying
all right and there were a lot as he
said I know you just said and he didn't
want it I'm just serious as you said I'm
curious why not and as you've said not
there are lots a lot there were lots and
lots of other things I know because I
actually happen to believe because that
what we were trying to do from a
strategic point I know trying to lower
taxes and trying to make the country
more productive and wealth creating and
was a good thing I know what you both
believed but it turned out you were both
wrong
the implementation was was wrong I
accept that I think the Strategic the
strategy was the right thing but again I
understand you don't want to apologize
my question is why because I don't think
that uh the strategy was the wrong
strategy I don't apologize for the
strategy I just think the implementation
and the way in which it was delivered
could have been improved massively and I
and I've probably
accepted you said it was a big mistake
no I said so there were two things
there's a strategic goal I want to have
a lower attacks Britain and there's a
way you get there now the way that we
the implementation we used I think left
a lot to be desired I think it was the
wrong thing at the wrong time we went
too far yes however the strategy where
we wanted to get to was absolutely
you know that's an important thing
that's an important it's fine but the
reality of your actions is it millions
of people in this country suffered
immediate financial harm and to those I
don't an apology from you to me but
there are people watching this so hang
on there are people watching this who
went through genuine Financial harm as a
consequence of your actions so don't
apologize to me but for them I'm really
curious why you would be prepared to
look down the barrel of the camera on a
show like this and not just say I'm
sorry so what I would do is just say you
know we could have done things better
but I'm not gonna I'm not lazy I'm not
going to apologize for the actual
apologizing yourself apologizing for for
the fact I think it was the right
strategy but the implementation was
wrong well I said next I'm gonna keep
trying and see if I can finally get an
apology from quasi-quarter
oh
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
apologize for the shocking I'm not going
to come here you always do this you get
people on and you want them to sort of
wear the hair shirt and no I don't and
humiliate them but I'm not I don't have
no wish to humiliate you whatsoever
honestly don't I have zero wifty
humility I actually thought you were
going to be a really good Chancellor but
what it's worth right well no thank you
that's right kind of you and I think
there's a pair of you lost your minds I
think we went too far too far right I
think I accept I think you lost your
minds and you got way ahead of your
sales but the consequences of your
actions led to you being fired yeah list
trust hoping that would save her skin it
didn't she then had to go to humiliation
for the pair of you and for the country
on the global stage but again I come
back to one thing you may not want to
apologize and I'm not after it look but
I'm not trying to humiliate you no no
you guys with respect quasi you guys
humiliated yourself well okay right yeah
but in the process you also expose the
country to humiliation it was a very
damaging period for Britain in terms of
our standing around the world and more
importantly to me millions of British
people already suffering from a pandemic
already suffering a cost of living
crisis already suffering suffering from
any energy costs going through the roof
all these things they then had the added
financial burden as a consequence
so my point is it was a very so my point
is you're a smart guy you know that the
decisions that you took led to that
Financial harm for millions of people in
this country why are you not prepared
see what this reminds me of and You're
gonna laugh but it reminds me of frost
trying to get that apology out of Nixon
for the damage he'd done to the
reputation of America why don't you just
take your Leaf out of nix's book he
didn't want to apologize either he
resisted for years and then eventually
he sat back and you can see his brain
weren't thinking actually you know what
yes I'm sorry why is it so hard look
it's not hard is it possible you're
literally finding your boss but look
there were other there were lots of
other people involved in this okay there
was I'm not you were the chancellor I'm
not going to take sole responsibility uh
when there were lots of responsibilities
I know I did I have taken responsibility
you don't think you don't think what
happened it raises the bars all I've
said is that I took responsibility and
and we should have done things more
measured in a deliberate way that would
have been have you heard the Elton John
song Sorry it seems to be there yeah
it's a good it's a it's a you like that
it's a very good song you played a lot
uh I'm not a big fan of Elton John but I
like that you know that song yeah yeah I
do I do know that's all so those words
resonate no all look I'm not coming here
to relitigate you spent 10 minutes no
not wanting to apologize
um you said the year not wanted to
apologize I've said millions of times
that you won't bear responsibility that
we should have we did things in the
wrong way but in terms of the strategy I
still believe in the strategy so I don't
see why I should apologize for this
because the implementation was a total
the implementation was was so when you
implement something as a chance for this
country that causes huge financial harm
immediately to millions of British
people the the traditional thing is to
say you know what I'm sorry for the
damage and if you look at where we are
now obviously you know interest rates
have more than doubled since I'm only
talking about the consequences of your
actions since I was there I think a lot
of them talking about by your own I
think thanks to quasi I'm talking about
by your own admission the consequences
of your actions as Chancellor and the
immediate impact was it difficult I'm
not going to come on the show you were
the one you were the one that caused it
no no no I wasn't the so we've gone
through this in millions it was a chance
I was not the sole agent of what
happened
why are you so what I'm trying to say
why are you so desperately because what
will happen is if I say oh you know well
then uh Jillian's got to say everyone's
got to apologize
that's important and I just think that
it's very easy to get politicians who
are uh ultimately responsible for things
to try and say okay I'm sorry when
politicians screw up badly and it
impacts on millions of people's lives I
think that it is not only to take
responsibility but so I've taken
responsibility I accept that the
implementation you know sorry I still
think the strategy was the right you're
not sorry for the implementation and I
think we'll come we're not sorry for the
implementation and I think we'll come
around to see they'll find it a bit
ridiculous no I don't because like
because look we're playing a game here
we're not playing games
it's not a game to the people whose
lives were affected I was saying that I
was uh completely responsible and not
completely responsible I was involved in
those decisions uh some of those
decisions we should have there are
people watching this now because
honestly I promise you I've interviewed
many people over the years thousands
there will be people watching this now
going why doesn't he just say sorry
what's the matter with him yeah I can
understand that but all I want to say is
that I don't apologize for the strategy
for the strategy I think it's the right
thing as we got to have you are alone
perfectly entitled I think we've got to
have a lower tax fine more productive
yes you can't well created you can't
have a lower taxation without funding it
properly yeah I agree with that and that
was what you didn't Thunder if we taught
if we'd actually talked through it if
we'd had time that was why in the Autumn
statement I said look I'm going I'm
going to have a statement where we're
going to show spending restraint which
will fund the the tax cuts unfortunately
and it wasn't a choice of mine I was
obviously sacked because of the
turbulence because of the market
reaction I was sacked before I was able
to do that and when Jeremy Hunt did
listro say sorry to you no she hasn't
apologized to me
so she screwed you basically stuck a
political knife in your back well it was
sacked and I think the idea was that she
was never apologize no no she hasn't
done that and I haven't insisted upon it
do you still talk to her yeah I mean
I've spoken to her when was the last
time well a few months ago so you don't
really talked to it
a few a few months ago in the house she
stabbed you in the back and so and so
once I was sacked
um then you know she took responsibility
we got a new Chancellor in who's still
there and a lot of the stuff do you ever
apologize for anything yeah I mean I
apologize in my private life the whole
time what was the last time that I
apologized I think um I think I picked
up my daughter from Nursery uh too late
and I apologize then of a couple of
weeks so just to be clear hang on just
just you're happy to apologize to people
at a nursery school yeah it would be a
few minutes late to pick up your
daughter but you're not prepared to
apologize to millions of people so look
for screwing their personal finance you
see my that's where I look at it I know
where you're coming and you think I'm
trying to humiliate you I'm not and I'm
just thinking from a public in terms of
public affairs and public life I think
politicians make decisions
um and they on the basis of evidence on
the basis of their own uh philosophy if
you like and I've never been one for
saying you know if as a politician
um you know you're personally
um damaging people there's policy
there's debates well no because there
were lots of other things I did not
personally damage those people you've
admitted the implementation and there
was a lot of questions so bad there was
a lot of context as well and you said
well forget about the context well no
you the context is important I know the
context I saw the reaction to your
policy and I think that yeah and there
was a white there was a there were lots
of things going on there was also the
time where
um I came back from Washington and was
sacked and you know I haven't asked for
apology for that that's the way uh
public affairs uh these days is
conducted and and you know people have
sincere beliefs and they want to do the
best for their country final question
they shouldn't apologize for that well
actually I think I mean you and I have a
different view maybe but but I think
you'll find it's my view is the common
view okay I honestly do and honestly I
did not get you here I actually thought
you know over time after a year you go
actually yes I'm sorry essentially as
simple as that okay and then you put up
with one day's headlines the Quasi quad
saying I'm sorry that we got it wrong
and I've damaged people's lives so I
think you said what you've got it's a
15-minute attempt and they might need to
the reason in your eyes wrestle some
kind of fake apology in my eyes get an
apology for the people whose lives
you're invaded is that I think the
strategy and I think in the long term we
have to have have a lower tax uh but
that's but that's different and I don't
think it is different that's that's I'm
not going to apologize for for what the
goal was yeah that's what I believe
you're perfectly entitled honestly I
mean this you're entitled to believe
that your philosophy and your strategy
would have worked over time but I'm also
entitled to go back to you yeah
implementation was I Reckless it was
wrong it tanked the markets it spooked
everybody in the world of of economics
and the consequence of that was you got
fired very quickly and the Prime
Minister lasted 44 days and the whole
thing brought shame on this country but
more importantly millions of people in
this country suffered personal financial
loss as a consequence of what you guys
did and I just find it baffling honestly
and I'm not trying to humiliate no I get
that because I actually I've always
liked you as a person and I did think
you were going to be a good Chancellor
and I'm sorry it didn't work out for you
but I'm actually sorry for the people
who lost money and I think they'll be
watching this going why I just need just
say sorry
last chance look I just think last
chance it was a difficult time last time
but I still believe I still believe the
strategy was there but you know the
implementation was a fiesta and and the
implementation could have been better
yeah sorry for that which I also think
we should have happened are you sorry
for that we should have had more for
more time there you go I'm sorry for the
implementation the strategy I'm sorry
and you're sorry for the damage the
implementation so so there you go you
know we've had this discussion I think
you're right to say uh on consideration
I think you're right to say people
should put their hand up and also having
put their hand up they should be able to
show some Contrition and and I'm happy
you are sorry I'm happy to show that
what I'm not happy to say and what I
stick to is the fact that as far as this
country is concerned and it's wealth and
its prospects we cannot tax ourselves to
Prosperity but like that that's a
different argument and you're perfect I
made that argument am I right in
thinking you now for the damage the
implementation caused to millions of
people you're sorry I I I show abject uh
Contrition I'm very are you sorry look
look I whatever formula of words I'm
just asking are you sorry I'm sorry
um turbulence that was caused sorry for
the damage it caused to British people
if if that's what you want me to know
it's what I want you to want to say look
what I want to say is that I think the
strategy was right I'm sorry for the
implementation are you sorry for the
damage caused I'm sorry for the
implementation and it was it was too far
and for the damage caused to the British
I don't know why you look there were
Lotus they suffered financially a lot of
people were lots of people no well you
were the chancellor okay I was the
chance of this Checker are you sorry for
the financial damage it caused to the
British I'm sorry for the uh damage and
the loss and uh and it was a scary time
and I'm sorry for that quasi we got
there okay and I've I've not tried to
drag that out of you no no I've not
tried to humiliate we've had a good
conversation yes and I think you've come
to it I've thought about what you were
saying yes and I thought actually you
know we've got to put your hand up I've
accepted responsibility a long time ago
and you've said well why don't you get
to do the step forward uh take a step
further and apologize and I've said you
know that's fair enough and now you have
yeah do you feel better now
um not particularly I don't feel better
or worse I feel I'm glad I'm glad you
have well I'm glad that you you you're
happy but I'm not happy I'm just glad
that you have not only recognized
accountability so I've totally ran
responsibility but you can also
apologize now to the people who said
I've totally I think that is the right
and a year a year on we've had an
interesting debate and I'm looking at
you know splitting hairs between
responsibility and
and I think I think broadly you know
people were adversely affected it is a
scary time particularly with mortgages
which are still going up in many
instances and I think on your on your
principle I think politicians should put
their hands up and say they're sorry
thank you quasi quasi good to see you
I'll send it next an inclusive interview
I'll be joined by the family of a 22
year old British student who last week
was killed in a Russian mortar strike
while fighting for Ukraine
[Music]
good evening I'm Piers Morgan uncensored
in New York City King peers and King Q I
think it's only one for one king
he's mopped your weight Trump yeah look
at him fail about working just because
their skin folk don't mean they're
kinfolks do you believe you can win this
war but he's making me cry again they're
trying to force you out yes I feel
betrayed keep it award-winning
Lucy letby will die behind bars and a
senior Doctor Who first raised concerns
about left he wants NHS manages to be
regulated we needed answers a lot sooner
this is what seven years down the line I
mean it's completely ludicrous we need
accountability we need performance in
all walks of life if this nurse had
misgendered somebody on a board she'd
have been out the door when they first
got together there were press stories
way TK team that would make her a better
princess of wealth Elaine Maxwell agreed
to be interviewed for the very first
time I obviously wish I'd never met him
Donald Trump has just said he expects to
be arrested at 7 30 P.M
the concelli party can certainly win the
next election yes
did he say yes I have taken drugs and
they bent the rules or lied on the visa
application form and therefore got it
there needs to be an intervention around
abortion laws Parliament is Sovereign
Parliament can determine these things
the rest of the world has watched on in
sort of mounting horror as this story
has unraveled for you it was incredibly
personal the death toll from the Titanic
tragedy has risen to 1522 and may God
rest your souls
yeah
let it roll
if we stop producing oil the knock-on
effect is far larger than just CO2 I
nearly have empathy when I'm speaking to
them I don't know you're probably going
to vote me off
some of them they're easily lit
you can kiss my American Air thank you
very much very nice of you
Twitter you Sons can you please
reinstate my account thank you that's a
threat that you'd be worried about yeah
so are you saying that you're being
overwhelmed that you're inundated we are
really working hard for you we're just
asking patients to be patient with us
I'm Barbie world you weren't asked to
give evidence to the grand jury I'm the
only one that has Battalion materials
you don't drink never taken drugs you're
stinking Rich should you be concerned
if it's on your mind it's on talk TV
it's about you and your opinions if
you're thinking about it we're talking
about it
it's all about me that's a joke
this is talk TV
[Music]
welcome back to Piers Morgan uncensored
a British soldier who volunteered to
fight for Ukraine was killed in battle
last week becoming the 10th Brit to die
of fighting in the war against Russia
friends and family of Samuel newey have
said he had a kind and giving heart and
always wanted to help people Samuel was
just 22 and was studying psychology at
University his mother said he didn't
even think twice would make a decision
to fly to the Walton country to support
the Ukrainian forces and I'm joined Now
by Samuel's mother Vicky dance and his
brother Daniel knew he's also been
fighting with the Ukrainian forces thank
you both for coming all the way in uh
today and you're welcome my deepest
condolences to you as his mum to you as
his brother thank you I've my brother
was a serving officer in various Wars we
know there's a family we know what
you've been through to a degree but we
never had to go through what you've both
gone through now I mean first of all ask
you how are you doing
how would any mother do I am broken but
immensely
immensely proud
of the the man he grew into the
sacrifice that that he made
as a mom would I change it absolutely in
a heartbeat
how do you feel about it you've been out
in Ukraine fighting as well you're
actually his Commander for a few months
with the Ukrainian forces how are you
feeling right now uh from a human
perspective obviously it's not a good
thing to lose your brother so that's
something that's going to be with me for
the rest of my life but on the other
hand the the progress that he made
during his time in Ukraine it was
absolutely crazy to see him change from
a boy into a man
um so from like a soldier perspective
I'm so proud of him what compelled you
both to want to be there I I think it's
more of a question of morality so the
way that we were always brought up is if
you see something wrong speak out
against the act out against it
um so I think it's just part of our
native to just help wherever people need
help
do you know what happened to Sam
I do
I do know what happened
um
would it be all right not to
to go in into
um
details but
what I do know is that
Sam was first in
and he was last out and he would not
leave his position
until all of his unit
were out
um
I'm pretty much that's that's that's all
I know really just
what do you feel about the cause that he
was fighting for
what do I feel about the cause it it
it's a
from a from a humanitarian point of view
I agree I agree with the course I think
that it is important as human beings to
to challenge
it's a challenge wrongdoing where we can
you know we're lucky in this country
that we have
a voice we are allowed to speak out
we are not oppressed to it a certain
degree
we have to we have to stick up we have
to fight for the rights
of other people when we say that you
know that they're not being given the
the same rights and democracy that that
we have
what are your feelings about Vladimir
Putin
I feel really sorry for for Putin I
think he's delusional
I think that he has had a life
unlike ass I think that their their
society is very different
I don't hate him I just feel sorry for
him
it takes a lot to not hate someone who's
been responsible for your boy's death
it does take a lot
but the whole reason
both my sons do what they do
for good reasons and
if I hated where would that hate stop
where would it end
how do you feel about Putin and what the
Russians are doing the same obviously I
don't agree with the invasion of Ukraine
it's a an illegal Invasion and it could
be argued that it is actively a genocide
um I've got no animosity towards
Russians
um during my time in Ukraine when we
take prisoners a lot of these people are
just young kids that have been forced
into a situation so they haven't really
got the the choice if that makes sense
or hold no hatred towards Russians or to
Russia as a country
um but yeah obviously the situation just
is what it is
um I don't know I mean it could be
argued that this is an overspill of the
the proxy conflict in Syria I mean if we
look at
um sort of the the Russian and American
proxy war that happened there this is a
director overspill so what we've seen is
obviously Assad's been sort of propped
up by
um by the Russian regime and then we see
obviously Russia trying to drive a wedge
in a natto as well so if we look at
erdogan's relation with uh Putin it's
very obvious and it should be obvious to
everybody that these countries like
Russia turkey they are the enemy of all
like democracy loving countries and
people
um so again I mean this is we should
look at these as isolated incidents or
all completely interconnected
um so I think that's what people should
should take on board will you go back
to Ukraine uh I don't want to say this
in front of my mom but one million
percent I'm gonna go back
how do you feel about that
I have to
support
my child in whatever decision he makes
what I feel about it as a mother
I don't think any words can describe
how much I would want to say don't go
don't go but
I don't think I'd be able to stop him
even if I wanted to so he will go with
love and support
as Sam been brought home yet not yet
we're we're trying to get him home and
we we will get him home
um
he it's a really strange conversation
that two brothers have had US post but
um Sam wanted to be buried
um that's a huge cost didn't didn't want
to be cremated so we we are currently
raising uh money to to get him home and
to give him a funeral we we would like
military honors but we're struggling to
you know organize everything but we'll
do what we can
whatever's left we
intend you know they're annoying of the
families in this country
who are going through what what we go
through what we're going through
but there are also families from other
conflicts
whose children have volunteered to to go
out there and fight you know we need to
support
what is the legality of what you guys
have been doing it's a it's quite a gray
area so
um with Ukraine at the moment um because
obviously there's quite a lot of uh
support from Western countries it's not
a problem so when you're making a
decision to travel out there please stop
here they give you a little letter that
says look you're probably going to get
hurt we've told you not to go don't go
it's up to you kind of like a disclaimer
yeah yeah for sure it just covers their
backside and uh but if we look at say
like Syria when volunteers initially
start going to Syria a lot of people are
being arrested for terrorism offenses
and stuff so I think it just depends on
on like the political situation uh and
depending on who it is that you're
actually fighting against so obviously
turkey being a NATO country for me that
was a big problem
um when I decided to to participate in
the conflict against turkey but
um yeah Russia being the the enemy of
the West is not a problem at all
this issue of when your brother comes
back getting military honors recognition
for his extraordinary courage that he's
shown he's not a regular member of the
Armed Forces presumably there'll be a
you know a process I guess which says
well it doesn't count
but obviously it should count
is that how you feel definitely at the
end of the day my brother's put his life
on the line and traveled to another
country to help people that need him
um I think Millennials are in gen Z get
quite a hard reputation a lot of the
time a lot of people say that it's not
within us to to sacrifice it and to know
what struggle is but I'd like to argue
the opposite we do know what struggle is
for a lot of us do give up comfortable
lives to to travel to other places to
help people so that's the bottom line
and I don't think
um people should ever negate the
sacrifices that have been made so my
brother was 22 when he died he's give up
his whole life for for other people he's
not going to have any more days and to
be able to to square that away with
yourself as a human and say right I'm
willing to give up all the rest of my
days for other people it just takes a
difference to fight for freedom and
democracy
which I think is the most important
thing you could ever fight for
absolutely and your son to me is a hero
and should be treated as such by this
country it may not have been there
officially but he was there risking his
life as it turned out losing his life to
fight for Ukraine's freedom and
democracy and I can only imagine how
grateful the Ukrainian people must feel
about what you're both your boys have
done for their country just before I let
you go just tell me about your son Sam
what kind of absolutely nightmare
he was an absolute nightmare so Sam was
born
with a unnatural confidence as a toddler
he he it was in him
to fight for what he believed even as a
you know as a child if you chastised him
he would argue his points and and
he he was
so funny so so funny got a great sense
of humor
intelligent he actually did um
he won Apprentice of the uh in Butchery
and he was uh presented with a
certificate by Princess Anne all people
and God love him he chatted to her for
an hour like she was an old-school
friend
I don't know what she made of him but um
if you if you had met him you you'd have
he'd have left a mark
it's obviously desperately sad that you
lost your son it sounds a remarkable
young man in many different ways but how
proud of him are you mentally immensely
proud
there were no there are no I'm
heartbroken but my gosh
what a man he grew into a lot of people
have have said gosh you're a you're a
great mom you've brought them up well
and peers I won't take that that that's
you know give somebody morality you
don't give them bravery and courage and
honor it's in there but
that's down to Sam that's not down to me
I'm so sorry that you've lost this
wonderful son that we've lost what
sounds like a great Brit absolutely and
I'm very grateful to you for what you've
been doing I wish you all the very best
if you do go back there Ukrainian people
need all the help they can get
definitely I feel that there's nothing
more important than what they're
fighting for definitely so thank you
both for coming in I wish it was under
different circumstances but Sam was a
hero and you should both know that thank
you thank you very much
well nonsense
the next and full of references that
reinforce white supremacy that's a claim
of the U.S academic my pack will be here
to debate that and the Very moving
interview that we've just conducted
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
welcome back to Peterson I'm joined over
my Stella pack talk to the contributor
Paula Ron age from the political sketch
Rider the daily mail again Quentin lets
and clinical journalist Ava santin
welcome to all of you have you missed
Stella
Pirates of Stella I know you haven't
missed me but if you two missed me of
course dreadfully
look at the look at the terrible
disingenuous Expressions I'm temporary
healthy it won't last long
um just want to talk to you straight
away just about that interview I just
conducted with that that poor woman
whose son 22 years old gone to fight for
the Ukrainian forces as she put it for
freedom and democracy with her other son
who's also done that sitting there
saying he's going to probably go back
yeah and yet there's no formal way of
bringing her son home there's no help
from the government the foreign office
they are struggling to find money for
the burial this doesn't seem right to me
it isn't right and I have to be careful
because obviously I'm a barrister and I
expect everyone to abide by the rules
and laws that our state sets us and
technically of course we know that he
shouldn't have been there but what does
surprise me is that our foreign office
doesn't have just an ounce of
sensitivity to offer support to the
family because it is the family it is
the loved ones who are struggling and
and and have to deal with not only the
loss but of dealing with all the
bureaucracy and rigmarole that goes with
bringing
um a lost member backed is kind of
Quincy it just doesn't but that's not
very terrible personal Misfortune and a
tragedy and once feels sympathy but it's
not yet a national war that we're in and
uh therefore people who go out there and
fight uh Europeans uh who aren't part of
the Ukrainian Nation then they're doing
it at their own personal risk they are
and I don't think they were contesting
that part of it well therefore if you
start uh then you know bring them back
and giving them military honors that
first of all politicizes it in a very
dangerous way but it also I think
dilutes the gravity of a Nation
declaring Wars I mean it's complicated
this day I felt incredibly sorry for
them I come from a family full of
military people who served in war and
thank God we never had the call that she
had to take that her boy had died it
wasn't there officially in the British
Armed Forces because we're not there
officially for that but he did serve
incredibly bravely for the Ukrainian
forces forces that we are supporting
with other military means in terms of
equipment but
ton so right so if we start I mean if
you start honoring British Fighters
who've gone on over there to contribute
then you've you've de facto got boots on
the ground haven't you you've sort of
put the British on or is there
distinction to be made that it wasn't
official we can still recognize that
somebody has lost their life fighting
for freedom and democracy I think this
is really tricky because I don't want to
sound like the evil witch in the corner
but I mean you you shouldn't have been
there and you've been told not to go
there it's extremely Valiant he did and
I I really feel for his mother I can't
imagine what she's going through she was
a very impressive dishing out honors to
people who've you know traveled over to
Ukraine I mean that that just sounds
like quite dangerous actually it's
complicated it'd be interesting to see
what what help we can get them um let's
turn to uh the other big interview that
we did which quasi-quarting so quite
extraordinary
I do a whole monologue about the
inability of public figures to say sorry
when they genuinely get things horribly
wrong they have consequences for a lot
of people
quasi-quarting spectacularly got things
wrong as Charleston which directly
impacted on the finances of millions of
British people and still continues to
and yet Quentin for 20 minutes having
listened to the monologue you still
refused to say sorry he wouldn't say the
words
and eventually he did eventually it was
almost like the lights came on and he
realized how bad it was looking that he
wasn't prepared to say that for the
damage he caused millions of people
directly financially with his policy
which went spectacularly wrong he was
sorry yeah why is it so hard for them
should they apologize first of all uh
well I'm not quite as obsessed about
apologies as uh some are
um but uh I think politicians become
hard-boiled against the idea of I mean I
refuse to apologize when I left Good
Morning Britain that's why I had to
leave but that wasn't because I directly
impacted because there was a principle
there yeah but he did he is he he
accepted that whilst he still believed
in the general strategy the
implementation had been terrible right
so he accepted that actually I I see
what you're saying but the politicians
become hard-boiled against
um somehow seeding ground uh to
apologize because politics is about the
Battle of ideas and they want to defend
those ideas but when something is is
goes very badly wrong in a big way then
obviously it's a good idea to say uh
yeah I mean either you could argue this
is one of the most catastrophic
performances by any Chancellor in
British history right I mean he lasted
just days as Chancellor the Prime
Minister who helped him in that this
lasted 44 days the worst prime minister
ever in terms of tenure so why not just
throw your hands up and actually just
throw yourself at the mercy of the
British people who are very forgiving
actually in my experience I just say we
made a big mistake and we're sorry well
he can't be that sorry because he still
took the 16 000 pound Severance that's
offered to Cabinet ministers and they
depart right so if he really was sorry
maybe he'd give that money over it's
probably about the amount that a lot of
mortgage owners have lost off their
mortgages I had wiped off because of him
I have to say it took you 20 minutes to
get that apology out of him
um I'm not sure whether the people who
are struggling to feed their children
will accept that apology or think that
that apology came from somewhere that
was real yeah it's a fair point given
how long it took him
um look Beth Quentin yes is Macbeth
racist so we have an American always
American academics uh assistant
professor of English at Trinity
University in Texas says that The Bard's
use of words such as bat Beetle black
and Knight are racialized language and
how did the scene where current uses the
phrase black Macbeth she says it's
important to help students see the ways
which a player may not recognize
immediately as a race play based on
radicalized language and playing on the
dichotomy of whiteness and Blackness and
dark and light the great thing about
Shakespeare is that you can put all
sorts of teenage literary criticism
interpretations on it and I think that's
about the level of this Paula I mean you
often defend the indefensible on these
sort of stories but come on Macbeth
races for radicalized language so I
think old Shakespeare said in there is a
little covert racists uh so I can't
answer that question but what I can do
yes you can well I can no I can't
because I don't know I can't defend it
what I can say is that clearly there was
racist language used what I can say is
clearly at that time they would have
been racist people what I can say is
that does it make it wrong for this
academic and Scholar to put forward
those theories and for those theories to
be tested
let me go over on this because I think
what's happening is there are academics
all over the world who know they can get
ridiculous click baiting publicity by
calling literally everything racist when
they're not calling it racist they're
calling everything transphobic and when
they're not calling things transphobic
they're calling everything sexist well
they're not banging on about sexism
they're banging about the patriarchy
that all leads to Barbie which is the
ultimate ultimate example of what I'm
talking about not everything has to be
all these things I I actually thought it
was really interesting I've never ever
thought about it in this like before
like I mean now you think my Beth is
racist I don't think let me let me hang
on a second okay I was thinking that
perhaps well yes the slave trade had
really kicked off then and Shakespeare
was at the time writing for Queen
Elizabeth and she was infamously kicking
out quite a lot of the black community
from London at that time she was you
know throwing Spaniards out and throwing
people back to Morocco so perhaps there
could be an element of Shakespeare's
writing that was appealing to that side
of Queen Elizabeth who like to paint
herself white with leads and was quite
obsessed with color well perhaps
Shakespeare wasn't racist I'm not saying
she just was one of the greatest people
that's done to everyone it was a
brilliant play right and didn't actually
have a racist bone in his body
Theory how do you know that how do you
know he wasn't I don't but what I'm
saying is it's important for us to
debate that it's important for us to
discuss it and well done to the academic
scholar for at least putting forward her
theories it was just a bit bigger than
this it was so so much bigger
anyway or he didn't write it at all
that's a good theory isn't it
unfortunately this show has suddenly got
so much smaller because it's over uh but
thank you to my my brilliant pack as
always as if for me whatever you're up
to Keep It Uncensored good night
[Music]
good evening I'm Peters Morgan
uncensored in New York City King peers
and King Cube I think it's only one for
one king
he's mocked your weight Trump yeah look
at him fail stop working just because
their skin folk don't mean they're
kinfolks do you believe you can win this
war but he's making me cry again they're
trying to force you out yes I feel
betrayed keep it award-winning
Lucy Letty will die behind bars and a
senior Doctor Who first raised concerns
about that he wants NHS managers to be
regulated we needed answers a lot sooner
this is what seven years down the line I
mean it's completely ludicrous we need
accountability we need performance in
all walks of life if this nurse had
misgendered somebody on a ward she'd
have been out the door when they first
got together there were press stories
weighty Katie that would make her a
better princess of wealth Elaine Maxwell
agreed to be interviewed for the very
first time I obviously wish I'd never
met him Donald Trump has just said he
expects to be arrested at 7 30 P.M
the conservative party can certainly win
the next election yes
did you say yes I have taken drugs and
they bent the rules or lied on the visa
application form and therefore got it
there needs to be an intervention around
abortion laws Parliament is Sovereign
Parliament can determine these things
the rest of the world has watched on in
sort of mounting horror as this story
has unraveled for you it was incredibly
personal the death toll from the Titanic
tragedy has risen to 1522 and may God
rest your souls
[Music]